so having said that the first lightning
talk speaker will be Ilya took off who
is going to talk about how to do data of
how to do good with data when the screen
works you'll have exactly five seconds
please give a yes perfect does this work
better yeah all right that's much better
sorry not use to my exciter so a
personal life story but first a couple
of questions so please raise your hand
if you are working in Western Europe
right now ok that's a lot of you who are
views on facebook who would like to
learn an algorithm that can distinguish
you and your person critic
characteristics better than your friends
but only 70 likes sounds cool ok so I
read a very very disturbing article the
other day and I wanted to share that
with you and it has to do with this
research and with these things happening
so I'm not sure how you feel about this
by friends in the UK I care for the
environment so I was kinda worried what
this means but I was even more shocked
by the fact that it was some of our
colleagues some of people like us who
really love data science and do data
science who are behind this Cambridge
analytica maybe you heard of it maybe
not otherwise find it they did they use
this research where you can actually
from likes predict what people do and
what people like and they made them
really hate Hillary for example by just
posting the right things on facebook at
the right time to brainwash people I was
kind of pulled by this and but ok let's
see what I never actually quite proud so
anyway and let's see what facebook knows
about me so apparently i started at a
climatic student and i joined this
company that's on this
slide and yeah I was struggling with all
these life questions like how to not
hate my boss how to find the right
partner in life stuff like that but then
as you can see I got a bit of a vision I
got some friends apparently I got a nice
hobby I got married so my life seems
pretty pretty happy right but so bad
news if you know muscles pyramid once
you got all the all the basics right
then comes the biggest question what is
my life about yeah what am I going to
actually contribute to the world and
yeah you might recognize this all of you
have good jobs you all work in a stable
country you hopefully have meaningful
relationships and before between someone
now and your death that this question
will arise I hope it will be earlier
than your death bed because then you're
too late but as instant very eloquently
put it how to make sure I don't become
corporate landfill so despite being very
happy at my work I actually started
talking to my boss like okay how we're
going to proceed and am I going to stay
in the company a lot and it had to do
with this because I really wanted to
make a change but after listening to all
the great talks I think yeah I would
like to save orangutans as well but I
don't know anything about robotics or
drones or mapping you no imagery so how
how do I make a change nonetheless and
what I want to tell you today is that if
anybody can make an impact in the world
it's us it's us here in room all of you
are very well equipped to do this
because all of these problems they
require some more or less complex
analysis machine learning whatever and
this is just a couple of problems that
we are facing in the world today second
of all you might think okay cool so I
all saw one of those problems but I
don't have eight or nine month to spare
to actually invest in this and then I
don't and I still run my thing into a
twist you know so it takes quite some
time but there's ways to do that while
keeping your normal life
so I had this conversation with my boss
and actually doing good with data has
become one of my primary things that I'm
setting up within my company which is a
company that helps commercial companies
it's a corporate landfill company if you
want to name it that way but we are
trying to do a good thing as well so
that that could be a thing famous when
you work at new on and you try to do
something about climate change you can
combine it would work i know people who
work four days a week at Egon and one
day a week their volunteer at Red Cross
you can give short term support you can
do a project you can do a hackathon for
an NGO they're waiting for it but
basically use all opportunities like
talking here and I'm also extremely
happy to be and humbled to be here as I
was what I was at the Women's March and
when I donated my money to the World
Wildlife Fund because in the end you can
buy happiness with money but you can
give it away and then you'll be happy
but not just money goes for your brains
can really make a change so let's make a
change together that wasn't but that was
impeccable timing exactly five minutes
if the next speaker can come up Tomas
clover please because you know this it
really goes by fast you know what they
say time flies like an arrow but fruit
flies like banana ah yeah that's
fantastic we can you have said it's like
plugin because then I can stop this joey
is enough yes one two three we give and
yes okay so not satisfied with the
constraints of a lightning talk i'm
going to attempt to pack to lightning
talks into the space of one so watch
this go lightly cook number one twice
and three statements org is the website
havoc on screen so python 2.7 is coming
to the end of its support in 20 23 years
from now and a bunch of a bunch of
scientific bison projects have decided
that in 2020 or by 2020 we are also
going to be stopping supporting Python
too so don't
Nick but if you are still using pipes
and tubes then start thinking about how
to move to python 3 this is happening if
you want to keep using Python 2 for all
time that's okay but you will have to
keep using old versions of other stuff
as well it would going to happen sooner
or later so fund the rates on that come
to a screeching halt switch to lightning
talks number two where I'm going to be
talking about what they put on the white
board which is MV vowel a plug-in for
testing notebooks so this project was
John Pistole here yeah shoutout to John
this is the cool project that John
demoed in the talk yesterday called
Engel ish for generating text that looks
like it's from a chosen language and
it's a fun little thing if you haven't
if you didn't see John's talk yesterday
kind checked out I just cleaned the
repository and this project doesn't have
any tests but it has some notebooks a
here's one of the notebooks in github
rendering view and what we can do with
mb vowel and B file is we can use the
notebook at a kind of very basic form of
testing so here's one I prepared earlier
because it takes about 30 seconds to run
in this case and this is a plug-in for
the pine test testing framework which a
lot of typing projects or I can use so
you do hi test dash dash NB Val lacks
come on why it's lacks in a moment and
it will run those notebooks in this case
it's found two notebooks in this folder
and it just checks that those run
without errors and so if the if there
was an error running that code then it
would come up as a test failure here and
each of these dots that you see in me
test output is one cell in a notebook if
I go back to the browser I have this
this notebook loaded up so we can go one
step further with this if I put in here
this by the way is a new feature in
notebook version 5 which was released a
few days ago so go an upgrade to this
this is sell tanks
so I'm going to add a tag to this cell
saying envy Val check output hopefully i
spelled that right so just do one handed
so I've added a tag saying only valid
check output you may know since I've
done this on a cell house
nondeterministic output that so that I
can demonstrate that this is going to
fail in a moment normally you would do
this on cells where you know what the
output looks like so when I run this
again unless it just coincidentally
happens to get the exact same output
then it's going to show up as one
failure running this test come on come
on Chris but you get the you get the
idea is it came to get into dirt did I
forget to save the notebook I forgot
your notebook tonight yes unsaved
changes there we go okay say that it's
not just off again hopefully this time
at work and and yeah the reason that i
use the relaxed version of the flags
there is that if you just do dash dash
md vowel then it will default checking
all of the output in the notebook and
often you have stochastic output so I
like to start with the lacs and then
tell it which bits to check you can also
start with checking everything and which
bits to ignore and they are you can see
that there is this time one test failure
in this notebook and when it gets to the
end here it's going to give us a
comparison of the output here we go
you've got the the two different forms
of the output there so you can see what
what's changed this is a really easy way
either for a little side projects to do
some some level of basic testing
something that you haven't written
proper tests for or for some more
polished project you can it helps you to
checks that your documentation and your
examples still run and look at I
finished in four minutes even though I
did to talk
[Applause]
[Music]
respect um so the next person and i'm
probably mispronouncing your name i'm
going to pologize before end bhargav you
see navassa that's perfect and he didn't
really put up a topic but it's okay
because he's wearing a google Summer of
Code t-shirt she's probably gonna talk
about oh yeah use my quito el de me and
beneath you you have an hdmi cable / yes
and you can put in the meantime I could
tell a joke ah how can you improve a
song about a taco how can you improve a
song about a taco screen working yet by
turning it into a rack working help yes
no maybe it's a take it out and put it
back in again oh wait yes yes perfect
five minutes starting from now go okay
so like you guessed is talked about the
google Summer of Code program and I am
so what is it it's students contribute
to open source projects which and these
projects are selected by Google so these
could be individual project which are
not done by research labs or it could be
like know things like scikit-learn or
you know whatever you guys use they're
all they're all counted and what you do
is you coat the summer way students and
why for students i just said count any
students in here any sort of students
okay that's 12 yay okay so why is
talking to do this will you learn a lot
you contribute open source which is
really awesome everyone should and yeah
just a lot of data projects lot of
Python projects and money they're poor
so we get money and it's good for
students and well if you're not a
student which is most of you guys
fermented and if you have an open source
project which I think a couple of you
guys miking weeks or small pet project
if you can expand the google Summer of
Code program is a good way to make more
people contribute to your project it's a
condom
oh okay yeah yeah help us on its way and
I guess this is good enough to do a
small pause unfortunately i'll probably
have to do another joke ah right this is
a good one can the kangaroo jump higher
than a house can a kangaroo jump higher
than a house can a kangaroo jump higher
than a house of course it can a house
doesn't jump and continue okay I hope
you're not cutting that for my five
minutes I'm not I'm not fitting ok so
for mentors why this is important is
because you can get people to start at
open source the second thing is really
important you improve the quality of
your package because again people are
going to contribute you're gonna have
conversations and students are sort of
smart sometimes and you're helping a
poor student ok so yeah you're helping a
post or not I think it's a noble cause
so yeah and details or unfortunately the
deadline for 2017 is over just a couple
of weeks ago but please apply next year
if is to a student or if your mentor you
can apply as you know you can help you
can even if you're not part of an
organization if you feel like you know
enough about an organization you can
just tell them you're willing to mentor
student I think even get paid something
for but it's mostly the open source and
all the love you're sending out and the
really cool part is numb focus which is
organizing PI data is also a g-shock
organization they have a lot of really
fun projects I work with mum focus last
year for my G sock and I would totally
recommend everyone else to check out the
projects which num focus are doing with
ji suk and just a glass chap I'm also
doing too many lightning talks some
selfish plugin this is about by Cobra
what is it it's the Python package for
regression analysis you can compare
different machines regression tools and
we can compare different ensembles and
aggregates you can visualize your
results like using box plots and QQ
plots a lot of built-in things which are
not so easy to do with cyclotron
sometimes why you should use PI Cobra I
wrote it sorry cool
it's a good way for beginners to get
used to regression I think it sort of
teaches you in a very basic manner of
how Lou it and it's built on
scikit-learn which means if you're used
to using scikit-learn you will be used
to using this oh it has notebook and
test which is one point over the last
guy I kid but I yeah so it has notebook
and test I'm still working on it's a
fairly new project and more details
about it well this is a github link it
would be really awesome if you could
check it out star raise issues complain
I like complaints that's good and this
is the name of the original research
paper which sort of which we are basing
our algorithm on so if you want to
google the research paper and read about
the math behind it you could do that too
knock yourself out and that's it thank
you ah so so you still have like two
minutes of grabs fine and thank you for
keeping it short the next talk will be
by Matthew wardrobe he hasn't written
down what he's going to talk about but
he can set up right now yes and he's
coming like a 10 second walk so then
probably this joke what's the best part
about living in Switzerland what's the
best part about living in Switzerland
notices a European joke what is the best
part about living in Switzerland
actually I'm not sure but the flag here
is a big plus
oh dear still is still really absurd oh
yes thank God oh no you sure because
there is something on screen ah Roberts
inconvience Willa well now yes almost
almost done okay get to you thanks Mike
Mike use my nitrogen I earlier yeah this
week's about in another trapper that we
had this internal tool for connecting
the video sources on whether to quickly
advertise it to you it has no unit test
it has no documentation but I released
the source code early in the hopes that
I can get other people's who who are
interested in it after this talk to get
involved and help you find that it's
called Omni duct the idea is that it
connects multiple different data sources
and it makes them a neighbor available
locally in a Jupiter notebook so for
example here I just set up a duct
registry which connects multiple
different types you can see I configure
a case i configure a gateway node and
then via that gateway node i connect to
https breast so high mysql any other
data sources that you might be
interested in and what enables you to do
then is to instead of connecting to the
gateway node and then on the command
line running SQL against press to a hive
and then downloading the CFC to your
computer locally for analysis you can
directly connect to presto like this so
you can go for some percent presto save
the output into a data frame locally and
just write your SQL as a Cell Block in
Jupiter notebook if you set up cash if
you rerun the exactly the same code
you'll notice that it says it's loaded
from case and it completes in like a
hundredth of a second instead of one
second for that really basic query and
if you want to rerun the query and not
hit the case you can run over the option
when u equals true you can also
introspect the schemas so I've written
prostitute schemas dot and if you
tab at this point in Duplin notebooks it
will enable you to enumerator or all the
tables the scheme isn't on the tables
and this actually returns in SQL alchemy
objects so you can generate query
through this and then pass them back
into the presto object so you can do
everything your nasty alchemy as well if
you're interested you can also push data
locally in to have you can read and
write from HDFS this is useful for
example if you're running high of
streaming tasks in high of using Python
manually connecting to the Gateway
copying the file and then checking it
works and then like it this just helps a
lot with the iteration process and of
course if you don't want to set up for
all of the configuration for like ssh
tunneling backwards and voids between
different services you can also just
connect it for a single service and it
still registers all the the Jupiter
magic functions like the % pesto and
stuff so if you're interested get in
touch with me the URL for the repository
is github /a BMB / Omni dirt eventually
we will gain documentation and hopefully
unit tests but you guys can help with
that thank you
so release early and release often but
in this case early we now have Adam
Powell also no easy already that's great
I might not even be able to squeeze a
joke in let's see how that goes why
can't the bike stand on its own damn it
okay okay so I'm kind of done with all
this weight yoke never mind not to go
yes thank you oh yeah so the bike can't
stand and so because it's too tired back
to you please use the mic please use the
mic everyone so I'm Adam yeah I work at
a company called catawiki what we do is
we are options off collectible items
very special items and I'm going to
share a hackathon project i recently did
and with some possibly useful insight at
the end so the idea was to make some
fake watches so we saw many relaxes on
the site and I thought why not try make
some fake ones otherwise known as dolly
watches because they ended up looking
like this so what did we do the idea was
detect the images we currently have
currently have four watches and Trina
generative network to construct take
images of watches for those that don't
know and the convolutional generative
adversarial networks which is quite a
mouthful there a form of model which has
a generator and a discriminator so these
are two models that battle against each
other and in order to beat the other so
the generator is it takes an input of
random parameters and it tries to
generate a an image from the
distribution that the discriminator
pizza so the discriminator it learns
from the generator and it has access to
the real distribution of images so what
this actually looks like is the
generator produces a fake image
discriminator looks at this and looks at
the real images which are it has access
to and it tries to say if it's a real or
image and this is fed back to the
generator and it goes back and forward
for a long time and eventually both of
the generator and discriminator learn
how to discriminate real images from
back ones and generates images so our
training images look like this very low
resolution mostly because the hackathon
project was two days and I needed to
have enough time to Train round one this
is what it looks like so you can tell
something from this so as the generative
loss from the model creating fake images
as that gets better then the
discriminator gets worse and then the
discriminator gets the upper hand and
you get this cyclical effect and but yes
we had lots of failures so we tried
changing hyper parameters we changed
more things we change the depth of
network and then we did more parameter
tuning this is a really really accurate
representation of the process and then
finally there was some success so let's
watch a train and then you can get the
full experience yourself so 100 epochs
it learns a blob with a dark area in the
middle so it's a good start then it
learns something closer to the right
color spectrum I suppose a little bit
more structure a little bit more detail
no the blobs are conceivably and if you
squint really hard they look like
watches and now I can definitely see
something that might be a watch and this
is where I finally got excited so there
are some definitely real watches here
and there's some more abstract ones
[Music]
and this is this is where we left it so
we left the training for the weekend and
we finally got this and you can actually
tell the time and some of these watches
it's ten to two on the bottom right
there so this is a this is really really
nice as a fun hackathon project but we
find that there was some useful stuff
could come out of it so the
representation of the watch is that it
learns because the convolutional network
we used actually was also an auto
encoder so there's a representation in
this center of that for each watch we
could use that to actually train
classifiers for brands and watch color
and straps and this is really handy
because we had a million images of
watches with no tags and ten thousands
of images with with tags off whoever
which brand it was and the color of
everything and the metal and the detail
on the face and instead of having
classifier that was pretty average when
we use the representation we learnt from
the gun it got much much much better so
this is a trick that you can learn in
quite a few places because I imagine a
lot of companies collect data and then
at some point they realize they need
more important more tags on them and
then if are collecting them but then you
want to use all has to arcata so that's
it for me yeah thank you very much yep
but you still had a proper 30 seconds I
mean to put pressure on you but well
done this was at a pal we now are at
number six number six we're going to
have a talk about single cell analysis
by Sabrina Kirsten if i'm not mistaken
yes perfect and as and I may have found
like a nice little short joke for in the
middle how does NASA organize their
company parties you know NASA we go to
the sky know how does NASA organize
their company parties how does NASA
organize their company parties they
planet please give this to a surreal
great plane hi my name is lorena i'm
working for coma soft it's a complying
company and based in one so surprised we
are hiring so if anybody of you want to
work in bham you can buy yeah i just
want to present something that
colleagues of me did and they have a
beer informatics background and they
created a platform to make single
singers well analysis which is not long
ago that is possible so it's quite true
it was developed because they found a
problem when working in this area that
if you have a publication of some
researcher and you have some data
describing the cell that you sequence
you either don't find the data or they
do not describe which algorithm they use
or which parameters they used so you
cannot reproduce the result so my
colleagues thought it would be great to
have a platform to share the data share
the algorithms or just have something
that summarizes all the algorithms that
you use such that you can publish your
results better and this is now the
platform for this so you can log in
select some data this is now already
given data later on in the project you
can also update your own data in a
private room and then publish it if you
want to so what we get here is now an
overview of our features we see that we
have some batches of cell sequencing
here and we also can filter directly on
the batches here I just go through this
very fast you can for example also all
right I just tell what it is about ready
okay if you have a single cell and that
we can analyze we want to know which
genes are in the cell and what types are
there ourselves and what we do often is
that we make some clusters of the style
that we found and try to find which
genes are similar used in in similar
cell types and what is it for for
example you have a group with people
with a disease and you have a control
group with healthy people and you check
whether the cells are different in which
genes and rich rich cell types so what
with the year is we have some clustering
and we have some self clustered
differently and we see here which
functions the different genes have in
the body and you can see rich cell types
paralyzed in which different functions
and to support the researcher with marks
we have a summary at the end so you can
just click through it when your analysis
then and you already have a overview
over the data the data quality then you
see if they're as the best effect so is
the sequencing was a good quality or not
then you see the details of your
algorithms that you use with all
parameters so maybe you could just copy
it and make a publication okay so this
is what you get there this is the
research project supported by the German
government so we're still working on it
and the next steps will be that you can
upload your data and that you can also
upload your algorithms to analyze the
south yeah and you can also come on this
which was somebody does share what you
did with your colleagues
that's it here if you want to follow me
on twitter there it is and maybe just
contact me if you have any questions or
check the website fast genomics org
thank you thank you I really was
thinking that we were going to have to
do the clapping whole lava people are on
time in this one was good the next
person is and again I apologize if I
mispronounce your name Chris sure Meyer
who is going to be talking about how to
map dirty data using free form text and
as he is setting up I believe I have
reached my final short joke which is
making me a bit nervous because there
are other speakers sort of coming after
this so how did the Amsterdam hipster
burn his tongue how did the Amsterdam
hipster burn his tongue how did the
Amsterdam hipster burn his tongue he
drank his coffee before it was cool it's
not cool when people already know the
joke yeah let's try to keep this up the
entire weekend and i only have long
jokes now which actually oh well yes yep
welcome you to this yes yes perfect
please give a warm hand of applause
[Music]
well I changed for title of my talk a
little bit there'd be more modification
and leary like change the title my talk
a little bit to do americans spend too
much on underwear based around the idea
of mapping dirty data to freeform text
so i'm chris i'm from the west coast of
the United States and so I think I can
safely talk about pricing women's
underwear because my background is in
computer chip manufacturing so the
problem is I have a friend who has dirty
data so basically he has this database
of entities names that look like when it
was more names that look like this and
APR percentages of debt how much people
pay for their debt which apparently is
not a thing here in Holland so this is a
really an American thing but you know
CID it's the idea can we go from B of A
to this idea of a bank of america and
then even more important can we connect
that everything else as an entity in the
entire world so first parts the PI part
of the PI data so the idea is that you
scrape data that has free form text in
some structured text so in this case I
actually have a database to work off of
but in general if you have any sort of
relationship like that you can hook it
up use named entity recognition to learn
the aliases so basically from that dirty
name to the corporate name and then use
the city of a knowledge graph to go from
the corporate name to basically that
entity's existence in the universe which
is a really really interesting concept
by the way none of this is deep learning
I can't keep up so but it could be
better done by Dave learning so bear
with me so retrieved free from text so
in the US we have this thing called
ensue or Financial Protection Bureau
where they have this database then
people say things like please tell me
that sounds stupid be of a needs suffer
for their actions and it's proof with
the Attorney General makes absolutely no
sense and it doesn't mention bank of
america at all but when they register
the complaint they have this weird
freeform text and they have the company
name so now we can kind of map that be
of a to that company name now talking
about women's underwear same thanks the
victoria's secret is
a very popular brand for women's
lingerie and they have a store branded
credit card and so we can also kind of
map this it's actually called victorious
Victoria's Secret this has some other
permutations so Victoria's Secrets but
the idea is that we can build up this
whole aliasing map there's this thing
called the IBM Watson or bluemix or
alchemy API want to start of the project
was called alchemy API I'm not really
sure what it's named at this point so I
put all along there but it's pretty
sweet because I don't have to build a
gigantic lstm I can just send it to the
API which is like the Python part and
then have somebody else do all of the
smart stuff and so it's able to say
here's victoria secrets and then it
finds that Victoria Secrets is an
organization and so now I know that this
is the organization that's map to for
instance this company so then I can take
that thing victoria secrets or the
company and then run it into this google
knowledge graph where it actually takes
it and connects it to everything else in
the entire universe which is amazing so
basically this is a what victoria's
secret is is this company that has all
of these attributes about it like who
the CEO is and then that guy will have
attributes about him like when he was
born and so at this point we've gone
from this dirty data to connected to we
can connect this weird dirty string of
data to anything in the entire world so
now we get onto the march steam actual
data part of pi data doing something
boring like looking at Bank of America
if you have a bank of america credit
card you can send in be of a and then if
we only look at the data points that are
literal be of a you just get these red
ones so not very much information if you
actually alias it then you have a lot
more data and you can say ok be of a the
APR percentage is something like twelve
percent and now the big AHA which is if
you do the same thing with Victoria's
Secret the APR is twenty-five percent so
it's about double if you go in with
these two credit cards Victoria's Secret
credit card and the be of a credit card
you're going to pay double for your
underwear
so the conclusion is named entity
recognition or FEMA form text can be
used to go from these dirty names to
actual corporate names knowledge graphs
can connect those corporate name strings
to everything else the entire world
including all of us and that Americans
are going into debt for lingerie is not
a financial best practice thank you next
up is who love Peters and he didn't put
in the subjects but I imagine it's
something with creativity something with
a I sort of creatively and probably
something with the I so this is I am now
resorting to the Internet what does the
duck say when he buys lipstick what does
the deck say when he's buying lipstick
well then let's assume the duck has a
Victoria Secret credit card but does the
duck say when he's buying lipstick he
says put it on my bill and as i said i'm
resorting to internet rule fastest thing
online now i think one two three let's
go yes so it was a very improvised talk
so I will just show some some browser
tab so people assertive okay mup like
what was only in this slice it was so
fast so the slides are up but I also
really wanted to tell a little bit more
about some of the other projects I'm
running with some friends so one of them
is good kind good life is kind of a
reddit style community project get Kyle
calm and we try to make science actually
scientific specifically for computer
science which means real science should
be reproducible meaning in computer
science we don't only produce research
papers but we also produced on the line
code as well as we share the data so
that's what we're trying to do here or a
lot of other people trying to help it's
a reddit type style community so it's
it's still paid out of our own pockets
so it means that things are a bit slow
so the website is a bit crappy and we're
going to upgrade it but basically that's
all this kind of wonderful research
papers going around and all of them also
have their implementation so it means
that here is the arcade link with a link
to the actual research article and then
there's the github link this is a MATLAB
script
that sucks but hey we have everything
and then some extra links and that's
about it and there some place for
comments so that's one check it out good
kites and whenever you find interesting
research just push it here as well or if
you find research and you're making
implementation maybe at booking.com
Oracle data driven or any other
wonderful companies try to give back to
the community and push it out on get up
another similar project is a creative
idea dotnet not to be confused with the
reason the maybe badly named startup
creative thought I were running but this
is another community projects were we're
basically trying to keep track of what
is going on in this new space of
creativity and AI so it's machine
learning people playing around with
creativity and it's more creative people
than usually machine learning people
playing around with machine learning
which becoming more and more accessible
to all of us so just a big list of
wonderful things like before I mentioned
like DC gun using what is called disco
gun to kind of generate handbags and
being able to transfer those into shoes
who doesn't want to do that then there
is the third block is podcast ethical
machine we'd love to have people doing
interesting things to talk to us so we
have people like gentle in or venture
capitalists or professors of
architecture doing kind of weird things
with AI so this is kind of a I on the
fringes anyone doing something not very
much mainstream especially again around
creativity would love to talk to you so
just send the link and then before I go
into an interactive demo well I go a bit
through some of the stuff i showed in
the presentation another plug for people
who like to do art with machine learning
toughing there's openframeworks which is
quite bad since it's c++ but once you
get over that it's kind of amazing and
it has things let me see if i can find
it should be did I close it with sister
relax of course I closed it nevermind so
that's that and then before we go into
the presentation here is another plug of
a
friends of mine Gene Colan artists
amazing guy making machine learning for
artists so these are different courses
on the neuro aesthetics and machine
Jennifer artist etc all of the courses
are online all the classes are online
there's videos there's extra materials
on deep learning this new stuff both
nuts there's demos there's code there's
guides there's everything and he's also
writing a book on it together with a
minor guide Francis and salsa check out
ml for a dot github.com if you want to
be creative and do some art
installations or whatever and then for
the demo part because nobody believes
that this was actually called it was
running and so here's again where most
of this is ripped off so with with our
company who have our for every Friday
heck days on my hacked a 20-percent time
was pushing putting all this together
which means I just stole things from
people Ryan Claris and Jean and other
people so we're learning up some data
which is basically a bunch of Flickr
images are crawled over the night before
[Music]
because it's done in parts and things
crash it means that I have to load it in
three separate parts then what we're
doing here query image we're make taking
a random image for showing it and I
think I'm almost out of time we're
having a neighborhood you could say okay
that's cool show me all the nearest
images do that how much time is it are
we done we're still at ten seconds ten
seconds so here we have it's doing
something I did something terrible
anyway the code will be on Oscars the
show did something terrible as you know
that load this takes very long whatever
you can see here this stuff it will be
online anyway but 5001 carried on thank
you nonetheless though I'm happy to know
that clapping is actually useful that
would have been weird if I explained us
you guys we've never really used it then
I think we are to our last chemo
lightning talk Speaker Robin sir oh yeah
okay so do this rights right
and where I'm from chronology works
different at nine mr. James Powell then
right yes okay we used to still set up
so there's this funny moments where you
have to imagine is a science fiction
setting there is space ship orbiting
around Earth with two humans on it and
then earth explodes and it's a sort of
very bad situation and the two humans
are looking at each other and go oh my
god what just happened and the other guy
says yeah I should have listened to my
mother and the only guy says why what is
she saying is that I don't know then
listen please tell me you're done I
really am running out now man yes what
you're here oh dear yeah yeah you'll
take your time yeah yeah noez just me
trying to keep the crowd interested just
you know not wait Thanks which side of
an owl has more feathers the outside
what side of an owl has more feathers to
the outside actually they do like that
one yes what okay now James get the talk
then we'll have a joke from the crowd
[Music]
Mike Mike Mike Mike there's a lightning
talk for a PI data Amsterdam 2017 it has
a really fancy sounding title but it is
in fact a combination of two really
stupid lightning talks so in the
excellent keynote that we had yesterday
morning people talked about what we were
talking about human or models that fit
into human comprehension that for
machine learning models it's important
that a human being can look at that
model and can comprehend what's going on
and so I started to think about what
about models that can fit into human
computation models that might not be
deployed to a server or even a computer
but that might be deployed to human
beings for them to compute as part of
some process and so here's a really
stupid example Savannah from Nam focus
who I hope is here in this room she's in
the back which is all give her a round
of applause for all of our hard work
helping put this event together
it turns out she loves Amsterdam she
thinks this is a romantic fantastic City
and she's lucky because the other
Amsterdam isn't always as nice as it was
or as nice as it is today in fact today
the weather is beautiful what
temperature is it outside what's that in
Fahrenheit exactly they can anyone
actually do this in your head can you
convert from Celsius to Fahrenheit it's
a very simple model but none of us can
actually convert in our head even though
it's something that would be very useful
if one day Savannah happens to move to
Amsterdam she won't know should I wear
shorts should I wear a jacket but if we
look at this equation we can kind of get
a a simple approximation so if we you
know 96 is about to and 16 is about 15
we can go the other way as well so five
ninths is about who distribute that
that's about half and 32 divided by two
is about 15 so we have to really simple
models for computing from Fahrenheit to
Celsius in Celsius to Fahrenheit I
wanted to share this with you even
though Savannah thought the 15 minutes
it took for us to come up with this was
the nerdiest 15 minutes she spent all
weekend and that's a pretty high bar by
the way but you know if you take a
Fahrenheit value / to subtract 15 they
could probably do it in your head and
it's pretty easy so you know if we look
at the extent it's a little bit hard but
what's a nice temperature in Celsius 25
so that's about 77 degrees Fahrenheit
I'd say that's a nice temperature
Savannah Savannah what's a nice
temperature in Fahrenheit 75 so it's
about 24 degrees C so probably all of
you would would like then you can see
our approximation is pretty close only
two degrees off in fact since these are
linear equations which would only really
see linear error here and if we graph it
over the range of human temperatures
from about negative 5 degrees Fahrenheit
to about 105 degrees Fahrenheit we see
at maximum about 10 about 5 degrees of a
difference which is good enough for us
to determine should I wear shorts today
or not now that leads into lightning
talk number to another stupid lightning
talk the lightning talk number two is
about the tool that I'm using to present
these slides it's called m12 I do a lot
of corporate training and I give a lot
of talks I give a lot of tutorials and
this is actually the 66 talk auditory
alive
since 2012 these days they never give a
talk twice every talk is written from
scratch only given once and writing
slides takes a lot of time so i found a
tool online called sent it was written
by a group called fuckless it was
written in c and i liked it it had a
really nice aesthetic i like this big
words you know monospaced font kind of
old-school hacker aesthetic except I had
to recompile the program to change the
background color and I thought that was
kind of lame so I wrote my own version
based off of sent called pythons send
was a thousand lines of seat so I spent
a thousand lines of Python to write my
own version where you could change the
background color and the slides look
kind of like this you'd have a file and
each set of consecutive lines would be a
slide so that would be I supplied with
the title of a subtitle slide one and
slide two and it support a lot of custom
directives so if you wanted to change
the foreground color you could put a
little carrot there or rather a little
angle bracket there you want to change
the background color you could if you
want to add a header to all the slides
you could and as I started using this to
give about two or three presentations it
evolved its own language which was kind
of lame so I decided to write a new
version from scratch and I did it on the
flight over from New York and I thought
to myself when I was writing that who
likes writing code everyone and who
likes writing Python everyone and
wouldn't it be nice to just write Python
scripts all day even if your work
happens to be presenting something to
somebody or doing some corporate
training and if we think about pythons
isn't it something of a system language
that is it has a lot of mechanisms a lot
of features and those features map
really nicely to the mechanisms of a
system we might create therefore we have
Emlyn too it's a very simple API it has
only four functions in it all slides are
just lists of lists there's a function
called Embley know Phi which takes a
list of lists and project them a slide
you could do something like this from my
set of common slides import about me and
just extend my slideshow with that so I
can import the common slides that appear
everywhere I slides just a list of lists
so you have the background the header
the footer in the slide and so if i had
a text file I could get to that
[Music]
so thank you James for bragging about
your own library then I think we are now
at the final lightning talk which will
be done by Robin Allanson which is going
to about how not to do a start-up
startups is the thing i have read about
these days it's this thing and you can
read books on them how to do
intrapreneurship like how do we be very
lean and you know you're at home you a
nice little moment to read a book and
you're reading your book and you look at
your dog is your dog's how nice and the
dog is sitting right next to your chair
and you really think you know outside of
a book the dog really is a man's best
friend but inside of a dog it's very
hard to read something I hope my timing
right though 1 2 3 please yes go briefly
this is actually like a four and a half
hour presentation i'm sure in five
minutes I want to remember three things
firstly have done a human computation
which said I just spend roughly ten
seconds on every slide so when I do get
to ten seconds cancel 10 in your head a
you won't fall asleep and B you lift up
your hand and I'll no time to move to
the next slide remember the conscious
mind is the sphincter of the unconscious
oh yeah I interspersed the the headline
which of the recap you actually need to
remember about 30,000 times through the
whole deck so you will actually walk
away remembering something useful so I
expect you to memorize this I'm a serial
startup founder a startup it's not a
small version of a big company it is a
with I feel I should get 10 seconds more
for people dying
my life is an enormous he's not looking
in the screen litter you actually get to
echo seconds just for that my life is an
enormously series of failures
interspersed by occasional successes but
I lied about my successes what you're
actually told is that you need to focus
on success actually what you need to do
focus on failing and learning from
failing so startups all about learning
you should do a lot of planning
engineers love planning I recommend that
you build a good plan or even a bad plan
and then you try it out find out how bad
it is and come up with a different plan
so this is the level of planning that I
normally engage in so the recap one more
time so don't build your own algorithms
use open-source algorithms focus on
building an enormous data set in a
specific domain make something original
original make something pleasurable if
you only focus on building product
you'll never get to sell if your only
suppose I'm selling you never get to the
real product so you need to talk to
customers get out of the building talk
to your customers and learn and also
build products don't copy the original
if you copy then my last startup which
was quite good start up in the end got
bought by a competitor doing exactly the
same model which was actually a clone we
were closing event the idea of a startup
is building a monopoly so you're trying
to build something nobody else has done
you can set pricing yourself in the
future and make lots of money secrets
the things that everybody knows not to
be true so it's not that the world is
not flat there's lots of things that
people believe which are not true your
job is to find those things out and
build up insurmountable evidence that
they are true don't do a start-up just
because you want money instead find a
problem you're passionate about don't do
a start-up if you've already got a
corporate job you ought to have a
mortgage you already married you would
have kids actually this is when I
started my site up at the age of 37 and
I'm not saying that all of your families
and slobs but
it can help focus on learning and
finding directions directions much more
important in speed right so don't go
chasing your tail a lot of people think
startups about being aggressive they're
not they're about finding the right
direction before you start going fast
okay so deep learning is taking off as
you may have noticed in the last couple
of days but it's not actually who has
the right algorithm who wins is who has
the most data and right now or the
become thieves have the most data and
most startups do not so you need to
think about how you can be still engaged
in this area and to useful things the
answer is well I'm going to come to it
so open source models are a enormous set
of change that's being swept across the
landscape and Facebook and by doing
Google and all kinds of enormous
companies are publishing amazing deep
learning algorithms that for free don't
try and compete with them don't try and
come up with your own algorithms for
existing problems use theirs but try and
come up with your own data set that you
can use these problems so what's changed
since I studied AI in the 1990s when it
was basically philosophy a lot of data a
lot of infrastructure a lot of learning
and as rule of pointed out generative
advertorial in your network switch again
so there are actually the USB when I
study day I people said why did you do
Dax it doesn't work that changed ten
years later it did work but not a lot of
software ten years later there are
things that it could do slightly better
than software now there are problems of
software cannot solve the AI can
completely different universe and so
again this is not the data you're
looking for
this is actually a very deep joke that
most of you will frankly not have the
intelligence to understand use the web
crawl the web and we're going to cover
this and then use comedian communities
are passionate people to enrich the web
use games to generate data you go again
focus on something people really love I
just really people go oh wait I add one
more thing I have one more thing before
I go so those are things you really love
away so there are 22 fish in the tank
and one set the other one so how do you
drive this thing yeah so it's been a
ride um servitor we have to plug this
into some level is they usually HDMI
right it's the tenants in the thing
James could you make a joke in the
meantime oh yeah the thing in a thingy
majiggy because that's not a joke James
but how many hipsters does it take screw
in a light bulb
well that's sort of the patois good I'm
doing my best but so you guys it's been
a bit of a wild ride so I have been your
chair I hope you enjoyed the conference
know those I have not been alone there
were many people sort of working with me
like doing all this I think it was a
good to have here maybe even a year
effort for most of us having said that
the tradition says that the sort of the
main leaves chair guy or girl actually
needs to present slides that he or she
has never seen before so what I'm about
to present to you guys I don't know I'm
kind of gonna have to improvise so know
that before I even go into this there is
sort of one thing on top of mine that I
do want to sort of mention at least
because one person in particular in the
committee who without whom this event
would not have happened I don't know if
Melanie's in Melanie ah great everyone
just give her like an hour's worth of a
pause
[Music]
so so if it weren't for her like she
works for booking it weren't for her we
would not have been having this event
here like in the end melanie was the
person who really pushed this thing
through and like just like most people
committee should really put that much
effort in it she got so tired at some
point she kind of forgot the time today
and it was sort of a funny moment so no
just saying if I were booking I know who
I'd be giving a race is here and we may
have that on camera so now we've got
that out of the way let's see what I
have to present so welcome my name is
Vincent I have not seen these slides
before this is my first time seeing them
I have no idea what the next slide says
here is my cat I hope that these slides
do not make fun of me the slides will
warn me if I spend too much time on them
yeah this is james bragging about a new
feature over the yag
[Music]
ok you get clap for this it's fine this
almost makes me fall off my chair anyway
this is because I talk so much so let's
keep this snappy I'm usually a pretty
carefree guy I love telling jokes how do
you know when Vincent is telling a joke
well no one's laughing this gets
applause and then I'm just elucidating
things you may recognize me as the PI
data Amsterdam chair I am in fact Dutch
so if you don't have any plans tonight
you can join me for a smoke and a
pancake yeah that's what we do all day
this is a picture of me overseeing the
committee so with that in mind please
join me in thanking Bernice Melanie
Cullen kunda Giovanni Gabrielle and
Marcel
and and against you can't see it but on
this screen if you squint real carefully
it also says hashtag give that person a
raise I'm just saying it's all so please
join me in thanking the platinum
sponsors obviously booking.com thanks
they're really did a good job at booking
this place go do is riven if you were
the training yesterday it's the the
company I work for Woodall so we were
happy to give you a place for the birth
paintings kpn thank you for keeping us
connected thanks the gold sponsors in
eco and new home for keeping us
energized one thing that like you guys
have all these smart sensors any smart
thermostats you really need to find a
way to get the ipython notebook to our
combatants also just saying then the
silver sponsors hto AI text colonel a
big data republic and observer yep again
these what's also kind of nice about
this is not just we can have a lot of
sponsors and I believe we have as this
conference on scooters I am at this one
we we have the most sponsors ever at a
high data event in Europe and why is
this cool and it gives me the impression
they're actually getting more community
in here more companies want to show off
more companies want to share and it's
exactly the thing we're trying to do
sort of move away from the corporate
lamps a little bit more towards sort of
the joyful landfill of Python and sort
of a happy pitch against fall into
because it's also joyful I'm also here
to mention that technically text girl
was the coffee sponsor and please also
and please also join me in thanking the
fine facilities folks at booking calm
because actually and again I cannot
mention this enough the food was great
but when you guys have eaten your food
and you go back here people have been
cleaning people have been cleaning the
toilets there were security people
downstairs they kept us safe because you
know after them so yeah even though it's
blinking I cannot thank people enough
when you leave and you see any people
still cleaning or maybe cooking remind
them that they've been awesome this year
and give there's a bald security guy
give him a high five and tell them
vision center so these are a list of
people at booking that we had that I
would like to thank i already mentioned
Melanie like twice or three times and
God this like five x rays is amazing but
one person also we like to especially
thank is a leaner she's been sort of in
the lead on behalf of booking and she
has also been you know pass for a bit of
stress I would say I think we have a
mysterious gift right somewhere so the
gift is here oh great has anyone seen
Alina cuz it's we also will get this
sorted out and do the cameras still
rolling so Alina thank you this is for
you you've been great he's given another
apostle
but for the very least virtually this
will resonate on YouTube quite a big and
last Thank join me in thanking the staff
of them focus in particular Leah silence
of Anna Mikado and Lynn Brubaker
Savannah here Leah and leaned against or
digitally aware of us to telepathically
in with us but give me another four plus
I mean Vickers have to imagine we're
planning this let's say like four months
before this conference starts every week
we kind of have a virtual meeting and
people from the u.s. dial in on every
single meeting receive the finances make
sense and a lot of back and forth so
it's actually in the US as an office of
people that are seriously spending a lot
of time organizing this across the world
I think predators are like three
continents this year as well so it's a
big undertaking a bit about non focus
Gnam focus is a non-profit as opposed to
a profit profit it was formed to support
the PI data open source community even
though num focuses more than just pint
and stuff because it directly supports
projects like numpy pandas Jupiter Julia
Medford lid so I could learn and others
um well so does she do these things for
conference like potato amsterdam today
oh there's a big lineup coming I think
Pilate a London which is the event next
month I also be there if you're
interested but if you're thinking I'll
London might be a bit cold I want to do
something else in May Barcelona you can
go there and if you think well you know
that's great but I really feel like more
like clubbing yeah that you can go to
Berlin and you know if you think that's
just sort of more the countries have
already been I'm probably just got to go
to Poland I care to see what they're
going to do so you're applied we're
already doing quite a lot of stuff and
as James probably ready knew I will be
at many of these I have nothing better
to do with my life
well then well I'll see you there then
[Music]
this is our second year doing a PI data
Amsterdam this number is not accurate
but it's close so last year I think we
just under 300 I think this year we did
just a little bit under this so it seems
like we're right now sort of a nice
critical mass this is a returning event
with like 300 plus people which is great
because it gives me all sorts of
bragging rights when I'm going to pride
a to London I'm probably the Berlin and
partly the Warsaw especially among them
because those guys been at it for a
while but this year it seems like you
might have more people than the
parliaments and bragging rights yay the
nice thing is it's almost thirty percent
bigger than last year we've had over 40
speakers and boy have they been great
from orangutang so getting the art of
working like the ipython notebook and
[Music]
they literally made me think very deep
about what we have here also join me in
thanking like the keynotes again I hope
you've enjoyed them as much as I asked
Catherine jarmel and Derek horse with
like definitely inspirational people i'm
very happy we were able to get them to
come here but with this inspiration in
mind and you kind of saw this with the
lightning talks remember you can be a
speaker too we got a lot of people that
came from abroad we have people that
flew in from like Silicon Valley which
technically are things like the other
side of the world we don't mind the safe
home gasps so talk to us Fox one of the
organizers if not for the conference
maybe a meet-up we also do lightning
talks at the meetup we kind of want more
local community representatives to come
in if your student or if you're like a
professor you got a thesis whatever if
it's something with Python and something
cool maybe simulating the English
language or you know risk analysis for a
board game come talk to us we're always
interested speak at the meetup and then
submit the proposal for next year also
know that you can be an organizer you
how do you become an organizer well step
one will be the talks are one of the
organizers and see what ways you are
comfortable to maybe help us out we're
always looking for companies to host
meetups and that sort of thing so please
come and help us with that the meetup is
sort of a nice growing bed for the
conference so if you can have all the
meetups that also helps the conference
and also helped with the conference next
year because I think it's safe to say
there will be a conference next year the
stage it feels rather inevitable yay
right speaking of the conference next
year we promised winners for the
scavenger hunt so the winners of the
scavenger hunt will be announced at the
next meetup which is which needs to be
planned but the price will be a free
ticket to the next year's events I think
I've already made the joke that you can
buy the early bird or you can get the
inception egg in this case the person
will win the inception egg ticket during
mr. by
surely I got used toilet and obviously
that's fine so on your way back when
you've given a high five to security guy
when you said thank you for the amazing
food and when someone has given this
gift Selena you may find a nice little
flip chart that should be pens there
please leave some remarks we love to get
some feedback but we also love to get
some quotes for the website goes to the
website convinced people that this is
indeed an awesome event it also helps
with the sponsors again the impression
we're trying to do here and you know
we've been out for a week mr seriously
curious on what you guys think and
before you go lost and found i think i
know this was lightning talks figure i
think right boom awesome I don't know
what this is but thank you thank you
thank you this may be the last night
yeah
and as a small personal note if I if I
can teach you like one last thing before
you go there's two lessons in life never
let your school get into the way of your
education and optimize for joy hopefully
see you next year